one boom what's up everyone welcome with
simulation I'm your host Don Saucon and
today on Sunday April 1st we're sitting
down with Nick honest hey thanks for
having me I'm super excited to have Nick
Nick and I met in 2010 at the University
of Minnesota it's been eight years it's
crazy to even think that it's been eight
years since we've known each other it's
blowing my mind Nick and I were exact
polar opposites
in freshman year of college I was
running around being social and doing
all this crazy stuff related like trying
to be an entrepreneur and doing other
stuff that was very naughty in college
meanwhile Nick was focused on his triple
major in linguistics computer science
and philosophy and then he was really
involved with FIRST Robotics I didn't
know about these things when Nick and I
were interacting we weren't really asked
we weren't anywhere near as close as we
are now now Nick I moved here six years
ago Nick moved here about four years ago
he's been at Google the last three and a
half years doing things like optimizing
their engineering hiring process so this
is gonna be a blast we've both been now
you've recruited me into FIRST Robotics
now now I'm loving it and you guys
you'll see that we'll post the video of
Team 31:32 Thunder Down Under
who won the Chairman's Award last year
at the world championship and we'll post
that video soon and you'll get to see
kind of what these these two sisters
from Sydney kind of how they build the
future with FIRST Robotics and inspire
people around the world with it so
alright that's a little bit of a
background about like us but now more
about you so what led you to even care
about these three subjects that you
ended up majoring in and then getting
involved with first walkest um yeah I
mean I think computer science was always
like the natural obvious one for me like
I started learning programming I learn
and CSS HTML a little bit of JavaScript
just on my own playing around when I was
13 I started like trying to program
video games after that and I'm sure I
would be horrified by the code that I
wrote back when I was 14 but I just
always kind of enjoyed like that you can
do anything on a computer and anybody
can sort of like the world is being
changed and revolutionized by this
technology and it's totally accessible
and democratized like if you have the
know-how to like get going and figure it
out you can do anything and I always
loved that that it's like sort of
creative play things that can change the
world yeah I the other interest sort of
came on a little bit more subtly one of
my big interests when I was in high
school because I always ever since I was
a tiny little kid since I was five I
could recite all sorts of facts about
the presidents and I really got into
political philosophy in high school like
I was reading some of Thomas Jefferson's
like political philosophy work I was
reading some Locke like a lot of that
and I thought I wanted to do political
science realized no I really liked the
political philosophy aspect of it more
and found that like philosophy more
broadly it really interested me and like
that sort of like methodologically
thinking about big abstract hard
problems yes or really the general tools
to think about any problem or the domain
of philosophy man where you and I bond
so oh yeah yeah and linguistics like
like it is it's a social science so it
has a lot of that like methodological
taking a part of things and I just
always naturally took two languages like
I took Latin in middle in high school I
took Japanese I took German in high
school like I just have always loved
languages and like sort of has a place
to look at applying that problem set and
just the natural intersections of like
language theory that's both in the
domain of computer science and of
linguistics like there's just so much
natural harmony with the other things
that I took my intro to linguistics
thinking that I would be a German major
at one point
and realize I really wanted to study
linguistics more and then that's all
crazily happening at the same time
that's that's a that's like probably one
of the largest if not the largest
workload that you can probably do in
four years did you do three and a half I
did four neither four but that's still
crazy because just freaking three majors
I never really stopped going yeah and
education is none we both know us
education is not limited to high school
and college education zuv life long yeah
I mean education isn't a place education
is like a way of being yeah that you can
go to a school and not be educated just
as much as you can not go to a school
and become educated exactly so as you're
doing that you somehow managed to get
involved in FIRST Robotics and then you
decided that this was something that you
wanted a you know going from you going
from Nick who I knew similarly to me who
you knew in college is so funny because
we both kind of took exact opposites we
bursted out of our our bubbles that we
were in I was in a bubble of ignorance
to all these important subjects that are
going on in the world
I was much more ignorant about them and
and I think that you were more in a
bubble of not be wanting not wanting to
show your true colors you're truly being
truly vulnerable to doing things like
I'm seeing a whole audience
nada at a thousand plus C Robotics event
and so it was very interesting how we
ended up doing that and okay so now you
end up ya gate you end up being on the
team inspiring the the the Gophers
Minnesota's the team to get better to
grow to prosper and then you start
mentoring you start and I'm seeing game
announcing judging like tell us about
this oh yeah I mean the whole story yeah
we'll give us give us a like a Cliff
Notes version okay yeah so I met it was
my freshman year I ended up
meeting like so many of my now wonderful
dear friends who had started go first
the robotics group at University of
Minnesota and they built robots and did
outreach I sort of came for the building
robots I was working on some computer
vision stuff
yeah and stayed for the outreach as it
were um I every year I did a little bit
more but we actually the thing like the
really seminal moment I went to the
first championship in 2011 yeah and I
had gone there like oh I helped program
this robot I'd like to you know see how
it does this sounds like a fun thing to
do
he didn't think he'd be walking into
Disney World pretty much like it
absolutely just blew my mind the scale
of it the amazing things people were
doing I I was just soaking it in me too
yeah and I went from that the year after
I became a volunteer here after that I
became a mentor the year after that was
my senior year and I was running go
first
yep that's huge yeah huge indication of
leadership and yep that's major yeah and
I have I mean I've learned so many
things along the way from just so many
inspirational people and you know my
friends around the world really yes and
this is this is very fascinating because
the story that you roped me in is it
three years now it feels like it I think
it was three years almost three it's
getting there when Nick roped me in here
in the Bay Area I never thought that I
would you know attend an event drink the
kool-aid and then just get
balls-to-the-wall involved with the with
FIRST Robotics but it was the moment
when the tiger bots won the inspire
award at the Daly City qualifying
tournament and this is a team full of
girls 13 18 year old girls and you know
it was incredible for me seeing a
incredibly male-dominated field of
engineering have 13 18 year old girls
winning the top tier award at a
tournament cheered me up and tiered them
up it was incredible that was my first
experience so you know from then on I
was sold and when you get to the world
championship level and you
see what's going on there you see you
know Brazil Turkey Israel China
Australia you see all these places
across the world that are that are
involved in and and this is this is
we're gonna get to this point of the
conversation later on when we talk about
what society's developing into with this
like kind of globalized state but the
kids don't really seem to have all this
nationalism versus collectivism they did
they just seem like you're a human yeah
and you care about FIRST Robotics like
you too you're a potential friend friend
and that's it you know it's not about
where you're from or what you believe
it's you're a cool person who does
robots too and that's great yeah and
that's all you need and then maybe you
get into some political floss as well
maybe maybe yeah maybe you do and then
now that can help guide the way that
they want to potentially build that
future yeah but I think like the amazing
thing about that is that rather than you
know sort of this like nationalist
sealed-off I'm not going to talk to you
it's you already have that opening yeah
and it's just a natural start so let's
let's do a little let's do a little
connection then to though to the video
that we what Ron but Ron giving me all
these hand gestures oh yeah look at your
Mike look at how you put your mic on
it's on the other side it's okay
it isn't okay because I can hear it oh
is it wiggling no it's just not robust
like it's where we usually put it it's
fine all right I'm getting better at it
every week we both are we both I'm
working on it okay okay so Alan learned
another lesson in mic placement that
he's no never mind you wanted to look at
a video or the photograph well let's
play yeah let's play the video first so
we have a video to show you the video is
what kind of what the kids build and
then the kind
on the size of the field that they
caught on and the objective and it takes
them a long time ago
about it is that they have to crunch it
the crunch time is built in six minutes
yeah so insane so you get announced the
game design to you six weeks in what is
it second Iike January it's the first
Saturday
first Saturday there of the year and
then boom and then you only get six
weeks to build this robot so you know
it's really this is why companies like
freaking Google and Apple love these
kids because they only have six weeks
you have this time slot you have to get
it done and they get it done and they
build these amazing machines let's throw
it up or onlet's what's up all right
there they're watching it so how far
along are they right now they're like 30
30 seconds in so basically what you're
seeing in the video is you're seeing
this team team 254 that's a team that
nick also mentors they're a team that's
won the world championship they're a
very very tenured team and what their
robots doing in the video that that
you're watching here is the objective
over this year was to pick up the what
are they building boulders boulders the
boulders and what they're doing is then
they're using they're using an intake
system to pick up the boulder then
they're putting it into we're using a
it's a turret it's a it's a turtle
shooter the turn in shooter yep and then
what and then what they were what
they're doing there with that green
light that you see Ron can you just go
back and pause let's go back and you're
good go and then and then just I'll tell
you when pause it if you could ready and
play play it again I'll tell you what a
pause it and pause it now thank you so
what you're seeing is that they're
taking a and Nick you Nick an obvious
explain it's much better than I can but
they're using the strip of a circular
led to reflect to reflect light off of
what our reflective tapes on that castle
tower and then that's able to set sable
to tell them and then they have a camera
for the vision to show where exactly
they want to how where they're
positioned on the field how much
strength they need to shoot that ball
with they get it in and the the
objective of this one so that this of
his last year's objective so we're
showing a video from two years ago now
oh my god what was last year's last year
with Steamworks last year with
Steamworks how is this two years ago
time flew so fast oh my god I was doing
field reset then I wasn't even judging
for FRC then so yeah you wanna yeah so I
mean the cool thing about and just to
talk a little bit about that robot was
that it actually had a phone that was
the camera rather than like a
traditional network camera that a lot of
teams use you know so that had an
onboard app that was actually doing the
processing hmm and it was sending it
back to the main controller so that the
robot could decide where it wanted to
orient the hood and actually at what
angle it wanted to shoot you know so
that you could basically press a button
on the driving station and drive near
and it would just keep it would follow
it would keep the hood at the right
angle and it would keep the turret
pointing in the right direction crazy at
all times yeah so crazy that that was an
amazing robot robot yeah it was and I
love how small and compact it is yes it
also had to go under a 16 inch bar has
to go under a 16 inch bar ever one of
those yeah but then it also has to be
able to hang from that black lever at
the end for a digit was a ranking point
for that yeah yeah so so this is two
years agos game then there's another
game from this last year called
Steamworks and then now we're in a whole
new game but Nick you want to show that
photo from or I mean Ron can you show
that photo from this is from just a
couple days ago what two days ago yeah
this is Nick and I when we were getting
ready in the you know Nick's I'm seeing
the tournament so there's like 2,000
people in the audience and he's running
it as an emcee and then he's been able
to train me as an emcee as well and then
I'm judging this so I'm helping the
judges run so that the judges can have a
good time analyzing all the teams and
giving out the awards but so it's a it's
a cool little photo the game's called
power up it's a different game we'll put
a link to the trailer in the bio for the
for the game but um first inspires dot
work we'll put that in there as well but
it's really important to get involved in
your community
there's a bunch of great ways to to do
so one of them is to go and become a
mentor for one of the teams one of the
ways is to become a volunteer at some of
the games that are being played most of
this happens there's a couple different
levels of leagues where we touch about
this in the video with Thunder Down
Under those two girls as well but Sarah
and J but there's a whole FIRST LEGO
League Junior there's FIRST LEGO League
there's FIRST Tech Challenge in the
FIRST Robotics Competition so there's
these different levels from all the way
from six-year-olds all the way to 18
year olds and there's different you know
LEGO robots versus literal pieces of
hunky hunky metal and computing that
requires a whole bunch of work like we
were describing
but it's it's it's an amazing thing and
I'm so so grateful that you roped me in
and that you got involved in really
young in yeah so it's an amazing thing
yeah it is it's so good and III what it
seems like it's like almost a million
kids are now impacted by this per year
it seems like it's getting there I don't
even know the number off the top of my
head every year it's going up yeah and
there's like something like a couple
thousand teams yes there's I believe the
FIRST Robotics Competition has three
thousand five hundred or so active teams
right now and are there like ten
thousand of the FIRST LEGO League team
oh it's tens of thousands tens of
thousands of these LEGO League teams so
that's you know and on each team or you
know five or ten or sometimes fifteen
kids so there's you know this is a big
deal this is impacting a lot of kids
around the world so it's getting them to
understand teamwork it's the emotional
intelligence as well the team worked
entrepreneurship yeah business stuff and
then also the hardware the software I
mean it takes a lot to run a team it's
not only like build a robot do the
strategy like make sure that the robot
keeps working and all of that but like
running a program you know paying for
your robot because those robots are not
cheap to build and so much more that
like it they really talk about like it's
not really that it's a program that's
about building robots it's about
building kids through robots yeah yeah
building kids
yes because these kids are being they're
entering the world post 18 in there they
have learned at least a little bit about
engineering these a little bit about
design a little bit of my math
technology etc but then they've also
learned about teamwork responsibility
accountability fundraising business yep
there's all these it's a really good way
to out of the world the confidence
confidence such a key because and I
think especially like the older programs
like they're given they're given tasks
that are fundamentally something that
yes can be accomplished by a large group
of teenagers but it's hard for them
and it forces them to be like to stretch
themselves you know and then when they
succeed that's a huge confidence booster
yeah so I mean I think Thunder Down
Under is an extreme example but like
they have become they've started first
on their continent yeah Australia yeah
and like they've really grown it and
they're starting to change the world and
then what they're doing the compass
Alliance is all in this video that we
talked about will it'll be up on our
channel soon we had to do remotely in
San Jose at the Silicon Valley Regional
which we were just at so okay so what
else
ties Nick and I really closely together
is this ridiculous insatiable curiosity
that we have this kind of desire for
being a polymath to learn a little bit
about a lot of different things at least
and so so mmm so this is one of the main
reasons why I would say that Nick and I
are you know are one of each other's
best friends is because we have all of
this insane amount of information that
we've tried learning about and trying to
be able to have conversations with
people from all different disciplines
and backgrounds about in a very calm
friendly way to try and figure out how
to build the future so Nick we've
struggled a couple times though you know
probably one of the times that I think
we've struggled was on because you've
you've had to teach me a lot about what
you've learned and from the huskiness
Peschel ii and you know you like this is
interesting you were teaching you I
think a couple of years ago three four
years ago about nihilism and yeah about
so maybe my first question then to you
is do you think there is a meaning or
purpose to life um I mean not inherently
no so inherently there is none because
you were just these meat puppets that
got birth through evolution and we're
just lucky to have to be conscious but
there's no goal there's no goal scribe
to that I mean I not by itself like
goals are not a property of an emergent
property of life like that that doesn't
make any sense right but if you were to
ascribe a meaning or purpose then I can
make one okay so so that's where we'd
make that's where we make the jump so
the so nihilism is inherently there's no
meaning or purpose to life but now we're
gonna consciously make up I mean there's
a question of how do you respond to that
okay and there are some people who have
what I I'm sort of inclined to say is
not a great response of there's no
meaning so do anything which that
doesn't sound like yeah no that's like
giving up hope Rhonda rod I see you in
the background I respect I respect Nick
for being a very intelligent young man
and he's think he's just kind of like
contradicting something inside yeah
sorry Nick I have a strong feeling about
well you know you say that there is no
meaning in life but then you give a hard
time to the others that if such is the
case well they're just gonna live their
life and they are
I am so right we do we do nothing about
no reason to stop them as long as
they're not hurting anybody okay so
that's what I mean well you're you're
comfortable in your meaningless life
yeah but you you you're failing to
understand its greater importance and
there is true meaning to what you do and
anybody else even these non doers or
whatnot just a whole lot of us the good
the bad and the ugly
you know who hit
well what next time you chime in throw
the robocam
yeah yeah I know I know yes so so okay
so the first step was there is no
inherent meaning or purpose in life the
next step is now society you're saying
so shall we have individuals ascribe
their own meanings and purposes to life
shall we have a collective prescription
of meaning and purpose to life I mean I
am NOT a big fan of the latter you don't
like the latter
I have learned of meaning and purpose
like I think I think meaning is
something personal like it's something
that a conscious being puts on their own
actions like I that's what feels right
to me as what meaning is okay and as
long as they're not hurting anyone that
was the yeah other that was the only
other little asterisk mark okay pretty
much yeah footnote do whatever you want
find whatever meaning or fulfillment you
want in life but just don't kill or hurt
people in that process don't stop there
I mean what do you what do you don't
stop there which is why I say that so so
I wanna I want to challenge that
rationality by saying what about what if
we could come up with a collective
meaning or purpose one one that was so
good that all seven and a half billion
people were like sure maybe like one
like don't kill right that that seems
like a really low bar for purpose okay
my purpose in life is not to kill people
okay great that's step 9
okay that's that's step one though how
about we get to step two maybe step two
is is work together to eradicate
suffering from other people's lives
I like that okay well there we go
there's a little I don't think I don't
think anyone ought to have to ascribe to
it but if we can build a meaning so
compelling that other people want to I
think that's a great project okay so
we're so we're saying that let's say
collectively a group of a couple billion
people say that we want to eradicate
suffering and then the other couple
billions say well we just want to
food and sleep and stuff we don't really
need to focus on our advocating
suffering some of those people will
gravitate towards wanting to eradicate
suffering some will choose not to but
it's better to not just forcefully
prescribe yeah needing to do so because
I think there's something that your
hand-waving just a little bit and it's
half a billion people decide something I
don't know if you've looked at like how
countries run themselves it's really
hard to get a thousand people to agree
on something at that level and a higher
purpose I think is even harder than like
what a tax code should be okay but the
first one should be seven and a half
billion people saying they shouldn't
kill each other I I feel like at some
level we've mostly done that as a
society Wow wait when did we do this
yeah because Steven Pinker can write all
he wants about everybody slowly getting
more and more advanced and sand
longevity and all this good stuff but
the reality is that there are still
these pockets of violence that exist in
the world and that it's really important
to and there's pockets of diseases
pockets of poverty and all the stuff
pockets of malnutrition whatever so in
order to address those things that's
important to highlight them target them
funnel resources at them time at them
all this fiasco I mean those are
problems we definitely should be working
to solve I love how we're already
unpacking this so well I love it yeah
okay so all right let's let's try and
pull another one do you think that the
again can we prescribe another
collective meaning or purpose to life
what about getting to the next rock that
orbits a star could that be a fair one I
I think that's a place a lot of people
find like if not meaning like it's
something that people see is like an
aspirational goal yeah and fundamentally
if what we want is human society to last
longer than when the Sun starts to
expand we're gonna have to do that yeah
and maybe even sooner than that so I I
think it's a massive project that's
emphatically worth undertaking but but
again it's not you're not we're not
forcing the sound 1/2 billion humans to
decide - oh you weren't you
have to now want to do this you give
them the opportunity and you show them
how valuable it is you inspire them and
maybe some people won't do it but yeah
yeah there's no point in forcing them as
long as they don't do something to harm
the other ones that are trying to do it
what but who just who's to say that what
by going to Mars what it takes is all
this pain and suffering and I don't know
if you understand that but just the
economy that we created for ourselves
and just the game the game that we're in
was the game potentially the
prerequisite for expanding society to
the next level I just pain and suffering
it's part of the game yes yes and we're
all we all agree we all signed up and
it's gonna be it's gonna be over soon
and when we're gonna get to the next
step but we're gonna be able to maybe
kid take care of the planet Earth as we
colonize Mars not everybody's gonna get
to go there remember uh uh uh audio Ross
Caressa
yes so I do Cecil he's he made a really
funny visual of like you know all these
advanced intelligent people living on
Mars and then we send this like rocket
full of people to Mars that are just
like these [ __ ] Apes humans from
Earth and they're like [ __ ] are you
doing here we're an intelligent advanced
race now we don't want to deal with you
yeah I mean that's definitely a little
dramatized but that that is a real thing
that at some point on the trajectory
we're looking at would happen like Mars
and Earth is is it three months that it
takes to get between them something like
that pens on the place of yeah yeah in
the orbit but I think approximately 69
okay six to nine months so to get to
Mars on earth and then your hands on the
side as well you can send a one-kilogram
package propelled by a bunch of lasers
and it can get to Mars in one [ __ ]
day okay yeah so that who's to say that
that's not already I hate to be it but
that's that's probably already happening
not technology to get to Mars faster is
probably already available just not
necessarily to us and I just
I'll leave it at that and I say no more
but we need to keep this in mind the
technology that is available to us may
possibly been here years ago to other
people oh but no it's not a conspiracy
theory you know it's not a conspiracy
theory it's just a suggestion of the
time-space continuum and it's very fast
and we're just a little grain of sand 25
years so 50 years but I think assuming
that we're not able to do things to
manipulate space-time in a way that like
prevents it if we start sending people
within a thousand year in style for
Centauri
yeah you're talking about lifetimes that
it takes to get between parts of human
civilization no then you're very very
likely to have speciation okay if not
Alpha Centauri yeah pick some landmark
but like human speed yes hey I hear you
you have a fundamental limits where it
becomes human life like Spanish so so
let's because of speciation is another
whole thing that we need to unpack in
our conversation yeah but I really want
to be able to progress from nihilism
like oh yeah I like I okay it's like an
evolution basically okay okay so we so
we so we've started at the root of there
is no inherent meaning or purpose now
fundamentally just you know do whatever
you want but don't kill or harm people
okay cool and then with doing whatever
you want maybe consider eradicating
suffering consider going to the next
Rock consider these things okay and then
what do we do after that because aren't
there more sustainable ways to feed the
population there's more sustainable ways
to provide water to people there's more
sustainable ways to house people to
shelter people to provide them clothing
to be eyed them with Internet and
electricity and education and healthcare
so there's all these sustainable ways to
provide these services to people that
are really important for their life yeah
and so now we're getting to a you know
we're expanding that list of things that
you don't have to participate in but it
would be great if you did decide to
build in these things yeah well and I
mean I think the other thing to think
about is like there are so many hard
problems so many things that
need creative and skilled problem
solvers that no one can do all of them
even the Elon Musk's of the world can
tackle maybe a dozen of them and there's
far more than that
yeah all of his attentions on Tesla
SpaceX yeah yeah vast majority so
exactly can't even do one yeah like we
started the boring company but when you
dedicate to a cent of your time to that
and open it yeah yeah I just don't have
time to do it yeah so that's why you
need all these people and all these
teams as well these thousands of people
at Google do you guys have a hundred
thousand yeah you're a 50,000 how many
people huh I don't know the number off
the top of my head it's a lot of people
it's a lot of people and that's why
Google is so much in different sectors
of technologies no longer like no longer
just Gmail and Android and search it's
now it's freaking Google X the moon
shots the all calico there's all this
stuff Google how many Google home many
hmm sponsored by Google hopefully one
day we'll get the good old Google to
sponsor simulation
Nick Nick work on that for us thank you
um Soho okay so good so we made some
progress we got to kind of the things
that oh this would be good if people
attended to these things
in Civilization okay great so we got to
that point okay that seems pretty fair
okay maybe we can and yeah I think
there's another step past that before we
get to the other stuff um it kind of it
kind of goes with maximize human I mean
I think and this is something that I I
don't think I can export to other people
but I feel as a person who has the
ability to do something about some of
these that I ought to yes but I I don't
feel that I have the ability to impose
that aught on someone else yeah so what
if I was to tell you that it is actually
your responsibility to impose the law on
someone else what if I was to say that
the reason why that person is so baked
in their own ignorance of a meaningless
life that they think that they find
meaning in just doing absolutely nothing
is because of their ignorant
and it's up to brilliant people to go up
and create stories or methods to get
those people inspired to care more about
this list of things to participate more
in it I mean I think it is valuable to
inspire people but I you can't win all
battles but winning a couple and then
other another person winning a couple to
try and get recruit people care more I
like to do my part who we're supposed to
inspire will will come our way
we're not here to inspire we can't think
about that doing this too we need to
just do and and and those will come
along they need to see us too and
they'll either learn or or not or be
dicks they'll get an opportunity to meet
this efforts or whatever effort you go
in and yeah don't yeah it's great to be
want to inspire but don't be bogged down
by you know not everybody's gonna if you
thought everybody's gonna love you you
don't know to remind you they're not or
that you're gonna run around and just
pitch every single person on the planet
no way or be that everyone's gonna be
inspired by what you're doing they
probably wouldn't don't what stop that
no dog they'll talk and data-id stop you
from doing what you're doing so yeah
okay all right so then we're kind of a
little bit of a split in that sense it's
like I don't I don't think that I ought
to go and tell other people that they
should care more about these issues
versus the I care a lot about trying to
tell other people that they should care
about these issues I mean I I feel it I
feel that it's hard not to care about
them if you really know them and
understand them but I I don't have a way
to tell people that they ought to I
don't have a justification for that may
be the justification engine is the
education so once you do learn about the
different things then it almost like
yeah like a power responsibility sort of
yeah the more you learn the
to be involved in it because you
understand how important it is to
society I mean I think people who learn
more feel the responsibility I wouldn't
put it you know as a capital m capital
are more all responsibility yeah yeah
okay so that kind of led us down a
little bit about maximizing human
potential because we listed all these
different things that are important to
focus on in order to prosper do you have
maybe something else that comes to mind
or maybe one thing within those
categories or something that we did
discuss that you think is a really
important thing for maximizing both the
individual's potential as well as the
collectives ooh one really important
thing um it's hard to pick one I mean I
I think the best way to like maximize
people's potential is to show them that
they can like I think there are so many
people who just see hopelessness and to
like show them that glimmer of hope we
have to tell people I love you and
you're beautiful and you're doing a good
job it's hard keep up the good work go
forward cuz we're all counting on you
you have to encourage because a lot of
that self-doubt this darkness - people
aren't achieving their maximum potential
is because there's something among us
that doesn't want them to that wants to
lead them down that role of self-doubt
and shut up mind your business and do
what you're [ __ ] told and we need to
reverse that and be you know let us be
achieve our maximum potential human
potential the humans that we can be that
we need to be now more than ever and you
know this is this has been a reoccurring
thing that we've been talking about the
show is this word confidence yeah the
idea that in order to maximize your
potential you need to be confident and
it's difficult to instill confidence in
people like Ron was describing and like
you were saying about hopelessness what
about the people that run around saying
I love you you're beautiful
we're all counting on you keep bringing
that thing into the world that you're
doing
and really sharing that love across the
world and then furthermore when somebody
maybe feels a little bit of that down
the vicissitude to lo of hopelessness
then there is that it's these strategy
these strategies that we can figure out
how to help people most optimally
everyone's different yeah but how can we
optimize making sure that people find
that confidence within themselves to
want to go forth and build I mean I I
think you set it right on it everybody's
a little bit different I think I've
found a lot of people that I have sort
of tried to do something like that for
it's well you want to do this
aspirational thing well let's break it
down what's the first step yep how so
you want to get here what's two steps
back mm-hmm what's two steps back mm-hmm
where's square one mm-hmm okay
square one is stretching yourself a
little bit mmm let's do that
you let's keep going let's chip away at
the problem let's turn let's turn this
impossible aspirational thing in you
know an impossible problem into two
really hard problems yeah yeah I like I
like the block one
what's the block one yeah what needs to
happen to get to block one it's a very
business strategy oriented perspective
to how to design that last step you want
to get to that last that bad engineer
work backwards backwards how do you get
to that first one how do you to the
second one what's the fourth one what's
the eighth one so so in order to
maximize human potential again
confidence is a major key it's being
able to say that you can and know that
you can that the impact that you're
doing is really important and have the
society around you help foster that okay
that's B that's beautiful love it and I
don't think we've had confidence yet for
maximizing potential so that's a good
one cut good all right
now we have a decent amount of
conversation that has led us especially
with what we were talking about with the
robotics we were chatting about
Australia Israel Brazil China Turkey all
these countries across the world we had
this example on the last show with with
Sara and Jay yeah where they say that
China and Taiwan can play on the same
team and they don't have to a scuffle
about any of the issues that they've had
in their historical past they can just
move forward and play as a team with
robotics in mind and this is very
interesting because their perspective is
very than we were talking about earlier
is a very you you dropped this in the
car though interesting humanizing versus
villainizing yeah that was really
fascinating I like that a lot
yeah I mean we have so much of this like
tribal isms we have nationalism we have
sectarianism where people are defining
like this in-group and out-group and
they are warm and welcoming and
everything you would hope to the end
group but to the out group they shun
they bully they whatever these
unpleasant behaviors you don't want to
see and that's in some sense like
they're sort of protecting their fragile
egos and saying these are the people who
are good because they're like me but
I've seen so many examples of like
people who spend especially when you're
younger you don't really have that
tribalism is strong and you meet people
who might be in your parents out group
and yet you go no they're my friend like
you've heard I'm sure you've heard a lot
about that in the like gay rights
movement in the last 20 years like a lot
of people were opposed to the idea of
gay marriage and then all their friends
and family started coming out and they
went from this like abstract out group
of like no I don't want gay people
we married - but my Uncle Joe should be
able to marry his partner and it's the
same thing like I've seen robotics teams
I saw one they had I believe it was
Israeli kids with kids from the
settlements like Palestinians and they
were on a team together yeah
and that's incredible yeah yep that
would be like Armenian and Azerbaijani
infer okay for us that would be very
fascinating and I think that'd be very
fascinating across all these little
pockets of the world that are like that
Israel Palestine okay with the
proliferation of information technology
we're seeming to become more and more
globalized seeming looking like it's
almost an inevitability there are a lot
of these pockets of tribalism still that
exist of mashing nationalism
sectarianism yeah where do you kind of
see this all going in the next couple of
couple years it's not a decade or so how
do we how do we work together and why is
working together um I mean where do I
see this going there's there's this
quote that's been bubbling around in my
mind I don't know from the life of me
where it came from
but it's it's been coming up a lot to me
lately and it's that things will be
neither as good as we hope nor as bad as
we fear mm-hmm yeah yeah and like I
really think that's what it's gonna be
like a lot of a lot of what this
technology this global communications
revolution has done is it's exposed some
of these and made them more obvious and
yes there's certainly the potential that
that could create more violence I'm sure
there are cases where it has but on the
net we have you know so many more people
who have become more visible and were
excluded like we have people who are
trans and acceptance has gone up on the
whole
so I well I think there's certainly the
potential that like sort of uncovering
the scabs in society will create
problems especially in the short term I
really do think in the long term like
I'm optimistic that people will listen
more and understand and get to know one
another's people and not as villains
yeah yeah and I like the quote about and
not being anywhere near as good as we
hope or as bad as we fear yeah I think
that is a frequent sort of iteration of
humanity just continuing to slowly
increase and make it better over time
but I do think that we face a future of
vast technologies that are used to just
be steam and then electricity and then
you know you would get electricity right
afterward even with iPhone you would eat
the iPhone pretty much right afterward
people are still right now getting the
phones right afterward the smart phones
so that seems to be very quick but then
when you have the neural prosthetics and
then you have the genetic engineering
and then you have the space colonies and
then you have the cryptocurrencies and
then you have all these things happening
at once AI robotics what happens to the
globalization at that point right now
eight people have as much wealth as the
bottom four billion people yeah where is
it that going um I I would love to be a
little bit more optimistic there I I
would like to think that you know sort
of the economy has built up in a certain
direction but it's always shifting and
changing and maybe you have a hill here
but it's followed by a valley as it were
and that I think more people will
realize that yes well they have less
wealth that fundamentally the economy is
about labour and they still do have
power and that people you know can go
people can go be an entrepreneur and
that yes it may be scary but they can go
and build that project that they want
what about when labor is not as
important in automation um I mean okay
so I don't know that automation makes
labor less important I think the
definition of labor here is really key
though do you do creative labor there's
a bunch of yes you do because labor is
not manual labor it's like it's like
factories you know a hundred years ago
we had people like manually making
things and we still have labor going on
in factories it's just a very different
kind and I think the people who are
doing things that are inherently
creative or that just like are not not
worth automating not easily automated
will be around for a long time yeah so
it's important to develop these skills
into kids these creative adapted all I'm
solving skills so what about the portion
of the pie that's expanding with all of
this and then what percentage is going
to the people that already have a
majority of the pie
it's an unfortunately large part like I
think it's important that we empower the
people who you know the the old middle
class who in some sense have become the
working poor that we find a way for
everyone to come along and participate
in this society as we move forward it's
a key find a way to get everyone to come
along and participate in society to make
sure everyone is empowered to do so
because it's humanizing it's humanizing
not villainizing to look at somebody
across the world and say that you are
still my brother or sister you are still
able to contribute to the conversation
to feel actualized and
it's getting a little bit it's getting a
little bit crazy when you'd almost
rather not take the risk of actualizing
these people just in case that they harm
the way that you want to progress the
our word so it's a whole new like oh
they eat people why do they even have to
touch the four billion this leads us
down the speciation conversation
it's class-based speciation of wealth so
yeah I mean I think it's augmentations
you have space colonies you have digital
currencies that you're in control of you
there's so many different ways
I think classism is just as dangerous so
tribalism as nationalism mmm-hmm and if
anything it's the one that is slow it's
on the uptick yeah I think it's
important to realize like yes we have
these aspirational leaders they on
Musk's of the world but like we have so
many people who need to be able to
participate to like the factory workers
put out in Ohio and Michigan and all of
that and like it's important to empower
all of them or to constantly run
surveillance on all of them and then
just prevent them from ever having
children again and then there you go
yeah [ __ ] em [ __ ] rot in the background
yeah welcome I know no I don't I don't
agree with that but uh now no but you
got a perv you have to present that
perspective like Joshua Kaufman did on
our show as well I was talking about the
janitors that work at Google now on a
MBA and I mentioned this to you on one
of them be a finals at a college the
professor left only one question on the
test and it was who cleans the room
afterward and out of I don't know how
many kids scored that question right but
you would be surprised that how many
kids would be looking at the final and
they'd be like what is one question who
cleans the room how would I know this I
studied all this damn text but the
point about it is is that that's also
inhuman the one that cleans the space
afterward then it's up to you as
especially in within business to know
about who damn cleans the room afterward
because that person is extremely
valuable to your business and in many
cases integral part of it and now the
whole conversation comes into play is
that person as replaceable ask somebody
else that might be one of the leading
c-level executives at than it is to
replace a janitor so then you get into
that conversation and this leads us down
a little rabbit hole of like oh crap
it's all harder to replace a c-level
executives ammeter how much harder is it
to replace a c-level exactly with a
robot or automation yeah I mean yeah
there you're hitting fundamentally this
like new economy how the world is
changing of information economy as it
were that like knowledge workers are
inherently hard to replace not really
automatable or people doing some sort of
manual labor are often not in that
category
yeah so like yes it it's harder to find
a c-level executive because there are
just naturally less of them but that
like doesn't make them any more or less
important and you don't think so so is
that kind of looping us back to this in
like nihilism perspective which is that
the person that's the c-level executives
or has the same level of importance
because there is no meaning or purpose
to the work that they're doing I mean so
if you want to define importance you can
it's not inherent okay okay so that's
why because the importance isn't
inherently built up yeah system but then
each human has the same worth in that
legs yes if you put that lens on then
every human has the same worth if all of
a sudden you put the lens on of now it's
important to build this company that
we're building then the janitor is not
as important as the c-level exact
you could put that lens on but I think
it's I like that MBA final I think
you're missing the point exactly exactly
so now these conversations that are
coming into into play is that like okay
now this MBA final should be you know
coming into your mind about the
importance of that person are they
equally as important as that as that
other person that's involved at your
company that handles the maybe millions
of dollars or the dozens of employees
what if what if the janitor has a
brilliant idea and if only you were to
talk to the janitor more they could add
twenty million more dollars to your
company yeah what if yeah or I mean I
think like an example that might be a
little closer to home if you think like
I I took a class on Six Sigma recently
and that's talking about operational
efficiency if you have a die in a room
2,000 miles away from where you're doing
the work deciding how you should make a
milkshake
you're going to have ridiculous and
efficiencies if you go ask the person
who makes it well show me what you do
that they actually have a better
understanding of the business then the
person designing potentially designing a
process for an entire multinational
corporation I think the people yeah at
the front you know have a they have a
better understanding of some things and
that itself is valuable to a business
yes if you want to put on more of your
in the åland okay so maybe the guy
that's flipping burgers is knows better
how to cook the burger than the guy
that's sitting in the chair saying that
this is the best way to cook burgers to
the 10,000 people that are cooking
burgers okay but it could also be in or
in Reverse yes yeah it could be
whereas they've been passed down this
idea of how to cook burgers for 50 years
and then they're the ones T on the ten
thousand hundred and what made sense
fifty years ago might not today today
especially when the robots flipping the
burgers so okay I like that path that we
walked down as well that was a really
good one
maybe we touch a bit on the vastness of
the cosmos do you think we're alone I
mean the honest answer is I don't know
and none of us know but like if I you
know put my money on the table is there
some other life in the universe probably
what would that life look like to you um
would it be intelligent I feel like is
the question you're actually trying to
get it I feel like it's plausible that
it's intelligent life is it carbon-based
or the do they have something that
resembles DNA or RNA no idea there are
other models that have been proposed of
I believe silicate based life forms life
forms that have it I believe it's called
left-handed and right-handed amino acids
then have the other handedness as ours
print maybe they clap like this who
knows who knows okay but I would say
it's plausible though there's other
intelligent life out there but if there
is you know it's the classic question of
the Drake Equation that you have
trillions and trillions and trillions of
stars and some small fraction of them
have the ability to support life have
been around long enough uh 105 about one
in five have appropriate planets like
you you keep whittling it down to how
many the Goldilocks zone yeah how many
planets are in the Goldilocks zone that
have been around long enough that are
stable that are like the right size and
depending on the assumptions you plug in
you're looking at a number that's a
couple hundred oh but 100 out of the
trillions depending on the number you
plug in and if you assume that they're
randomly distributed throughout the
cosmos it's probably the nearest one
it's probably that could have
life which isn't to say that it does the
nearest one is probably millions of
light years away so is there other life
out there probably is it intelligent
maybe will we ever talk to it pretty
unlikely so if we get to the next couple
of rocks and we survive maybe get to the
next star system or to I think it's more
likely that we get to talk to them that
increases the odds but the next star
system is a light year away for now yeah
yeah it's pocket change compared to the
distance we're likely to eat from the
next nearest four and a quarter action
for a quarter is that it yeah but okay
and and I I'm glad that you you know I'm
glad you provide a an answer that's you
know a lot of people have given a
similar answer to that to that question
and yeah it's an intelligent people
really I mean difficult to say yes no
right so you say yeah maybe probably but
at the same time it's just pretty
[ __ ] we're pretty sure we're pretty
sure we just need to find it ya know now
Duke now do I think that now this is a
good question do you think it's gonna
have to take until we find an alien
civilization before we realize that
we're all one tribe on earth I don't
think we are but we need to understand
why I don't think we all come from the
same place I'm just saying we don't all
come from the evolution of well it could
be a different experiments you know
there's different cultures there's
different levels of spiritual
understanding everybody thinks they're
right that's one thing we do have in
common you know but but we're obviously
not off on this planet we're not all
from this planet
it just doesn't appear as if so so so
Iran is potentially saying is that all
the different cultural experiments that
are occurring on the
planet this could potentially be that
it's all from evolution it could all
potentially be from whoa maybe there was
some life seeded from another planet or
from another part of the cosmos and then
we had a seat on Earth as well so could
that be part of it I mean one of the
theories of how life came to earth that
admittedly doesn't actually solve how
life came to be is I believe it's called
panspermia you know the idea that like
maybe an asteroid had simple life forms
on it and those have become everything
we see today so that's certainly
possible
um and frankly the answer is we don't
know and the evidence is probably
billions of years gone at this point to
be sure and I think there might be a way
to recover and figure that out down the
line especially if we tap into the code
of the simulation to figure it out now
Nick do you think we are in a computer
simulation um this is another one and I
think and I think especially when you
talk to a lot of people who are sort of
science minded you'll get this answer of
it's important to be sort of
intellectually honest about what you
know and what you don't know right the
answer is I don't know and it's hard to
find evidence the important the critical
question is is it possible to simulate
not only intelligent life is it possible
to simulate a universe and is there a
maximum simulation depth as it were what
do you think um I think there is
probably a maximum simulation depth but
it's also probably possible to simulate
a universe so what would be the
simulation depth so it's it's it's a
fundamental information theory problem
you could not simulate our universe
inside of our universe because you would
need the entire universe just to hold
the memory of our universe it would take
the entire state of the universe to hold
the state of our universe there is
unlimited depth if we're in a simulation
which is in a simulation
hissing bow so then you have to inquire
about the properties of like what kind
of universe would it take to simulate
ours it would need to be like
necessarily larger that would be
multi-dimensional like I only need a
couple of fusion a little bit of fusion
a little bit of stars you know well a
little bit of computing but it would
still you would need something that was
able to hold the state information of
the universe like yes you could you
could play tricks you could only you
know like in terms of CPU usage as it
were like you could only process the
things that have like observers or
whatever whatever it is you're wanting
to define you could use like less CPU as
it were thank you
I wasn't listening I didn't have my
headphones on I hope it was fine yeah it
might have not been optimal yeah but you
you really do have a memory problem of
containing all of the information in the
universe
you need something bigger like if there
is a four-dimensional universe that's
simulating ours I could believe it could
hold the whole thing could we be
simulated inside of a three-dimensional
universe the thing doing the simulating
would have to be as big as our universe
oh sure sure once you add the next so
like are there multi-dimensional
universes that could simulate ours I
have no idea is it possible in principle
probably how about what do you think the
most beautiful thing in the world
the most beautiful thing in the world I
would have to say and it's a it could be
so-called something of a secular
spirituality that we you know as made up
of the things in the universe birthed by
the stars all of our carbon that we are
how the universe observes itself
I do really like that one we are the
University of deserving and experiencing
itself yeah yeah yeah it's one of my
favorite ones I actually said those
lyrics in Matthews song it's very funny
so last question what is something that
you believe to be true that nobody else
believes to be true I'm not sure it's
something that I would say that nobody
believes to be true but certainly
something that is not commonly believed
to be true I think that young people
have not only the passion and the
excitement to do big things but I think
they increasingly have the power to do
so I think that you know we think a lot
about like there's sort of this idea and
I don't really have like a good phrase
to put it in but this idea of like we
have people who are very young we're
excited and know nothing in the
workforce and we have people who are you
know graying and knowledgeable but they
don't have the energy to do anything
anymore and like this power versus
knowledge growth trajectory
I think that's a myth yeah like I think
young people have a lot of power and the
more that technology democratizes the
more we have people who are able to
change the world given a little bit of
know-how and I think a lot of people
underestimate that that's a good that
also really brings me into the most
beautiful thing in the world as well hmm
the kind of those are kind of yeah
that's both very um not common to be
said by people but also extremely
beautiful and you definitely see that in
the eyes of all of the kids that you get
network with and I've really got to see
it as well and the last thing that you
want is to be a young person saying
something really interesting to somebody
and for them
to give you the whole ageism [ __ ]
yeah what do you know and I mean I it
sort of matches my lived experience like
I've met so many amazing young people
who are doing things that others might
not think that they could work should
yeah
and I've you know sort of as it were
I've pulled forward the veil and I've
seen through it you know I've seen that
the man on the other side is really not
a wizard
I quiet you clinking collecting
collecting of Cola Janus jug oh sorry
what did you what a great way to come to
close on our episode we covered a lot
yeah thanks again for having me Alan
Nick always so always a pleasure
anytime more amazing conversations to
come more great inspiration to be had
not only from these conversations but
also from potentially getting more
people involved in in great endeavors
like FIRST Robotics force inspires dot
work become a volunteer become a mentor
check them out
some more conversations to be had around
the subjects of globalization wealth
inequality maximizing potential what do
you guys think let us know write in the
comments below send us an email
simulation series at gmail.com let us
know like comment subscribe if you had a
good time we'd love to keep the
conversation going share it with other
people we'd love for them to also check
it out if you really find the content
useful become a patron it helps us keep
the studio alive those lights on the
internet connection
we paid two hundred and seventy two
dollars a month and this [ __ ] that's a
lot of goddamn money
50 Meg's up 50 Meg's down symmetric it's
crazy
why like we need to get them as our damn
sponsor so a lot of costs that we incur
you'd help us a lot if you could join in
anything dollar $2 $3 $50 whatever give
it to us per month we'd appreciate it
greatly thank you very much again much
appreciate thank you to all the great
family offices that also support the
studio Thank you Thank You Ronnie Vargas
our producer and director thank you very
much and we'll see you guys again soon
tomorrow we got to epic people coming in
and we'll one of them's vyas one of the
leading AI researchers Roman and then we
have also Robert Griffiths coming in
who's earning for governor later in the
day so much love
Takuma soon peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]